these boys in bradford take training
seriously many of them dream of one day
turning professional
they may have been at school during
azeem rafiq's testimony but they are
very aware of what he's gone through
while playing first class cricket people
are picking on the screen plan and it
does not nice
iron son is 12 years old and would love
to play for yorkshire
but he was upset to hear the allegations
against the club he loves
this made me think about like why people
do that at such a like high level
because it takes effort to get there and
he's um
rafiq he tried hard to get there so like
he shouldn't like be
having to face like bullying or this
sort of stuff
sayed shimei hussain feels let down by
what happened to rafiq
this really doesn't help like kids like
us to progress it doesn't it doesn't
boost our confidence it lowers our
confidence and just makes really
disappointed for seeing what's happening
right now their coach says there's
racism in grassroots cricket too to be
honest with you i have come across it
where we've played away
teams
where
it's not actually players it
comes from the spectators the parents
where you get the odd comment here and
there the p word things like that
these children feel the weight of the
words of a british asian player who says
racism cost him his career
they're hoping changes will come out of
this moment and make all the difference
to their futures becky cottrell sky news
bradford
[Music]